stellt euch vor ihr fahrrad auto ohne
auto zu fahren kein im stau stehen weil
die autos intelligent miteinander
kommunizieren keine abgase weil er mit
strom fährt und vor allem kein fahren
müssen weil euer auto für euch lenken so
sind wohl der traum von der zukunft des
autos aus aber so futuristisch ist das
gar nicht elektroautos sind längst im
mainstream angekommen und
assistenzsysteme machen das fahren immer
angenehmer und sicherer war in diesem
video möchte ich aber selbst den traum
der neuen autonom mobilitäts träumen und
mein eigenes und vor allem
selbstfahrende elektroauto entwerfen und
bauen im maßstab 1 zu 14 dafür werde ich
mit meinem intervideo beschreibung
verlinken ein videostudio pc von mit
kommt nicht nur alle teile selbst
zeichnen uns 3d modellieren sondern auch
schon vorab 3d renderings meines autos
erstellen und das fahrverhalten samt
raytracing am pc simulieren bevor ich
das fahrzeug bauen damit ich nicht wenn
ich keine fehler macht ist noch mal neu
machen muss ihn ist es also ein selbst
fand das auto zu bauen als kompletter
nun die idee ist genauso verrückt wie
sie klingt und schuld daran dass auf
diesem kanal seit drei wochen keine
video mehr kann dieses video wird
unterstützt von midcom und nvidia da ich
das ganze teil ja selber bau kann ich
erst so aussehen lassen wie ich will und
werde es deshalb einfach an cyber- truck
anlehnen ich denke das passt gut weil
das ja auch ein selbst fans auto werden
soll aber eben auch weil es super cool
aussieht und die kantige karosse für
mich auch leichter herzustellen sein
wird als die herkömmlichen autodesigns
die ja überall komplizierte kurven haben
die basis meines fahrzeugs bildet wie
bei jedem auto das so genannte chassis
bzw vorgestellt alle anderen teile des
autos werden dann daran montiert dann
sind natürlich einmal felgen essentiell
denen ich eine sechseckige verblendung
verpasste und auf die dann natürlich die
reifen gespannt werden damit die motoren
und achsen und sonstiges alles am fleck
bleibt messe ich diese teile genau aus
wo die lehre sie inzwischen 36 die nach
und erstelle einige fassungen und
halterungen und winkel das alles geht
später in den 3d drucker sogar die
gummireifen in die mitte kommt dann die
ganze elektronik und zwar ein ganz
kleiner pc einem chat name den ich von
nvidia bekommen habe über die elektronik
werden dann die beiden hinteren motoren
angesteuert für schub aber auch der
schritt motor der die lenkung vorne
übernimmt und an den minicomputer werde
ich nachher sogar eine kleine kamera
anschließen was später mal viele
künstliche intelligenz geschichten
möglich macht und über einen wlan stick
hat das auto sogar internet und kann von
überall aus gesteuert werden damit die
elektronik sicher verpackt ist aber
natürlich auch damit dass das ding
überhaupt aus wie ein auto kommt eine
hübsche kantige karosserie drumherum
jetzt sage ich natürlich noch original
gar nichts von diesem auto gebaut auch
wenn ich schon einige tage dran sitzen
ist ja existiert alles nur auf papier
trotzdem kann ich schon mal simulieren
und realistische renderings erstellen
damit ich vorher schon weiß was am ende
aussieht und eben erst dann zu bauen
wenn ich mit allem zufrieden bin weil
erst zu bauen und danach feststellen
dass man mit dem was nicht zufrieden ist
das ist die falsche reihenfolge das
alles ermöglicht der pcd mehr mitkommen
und nvidia zur verfügung gestellt haben
der genau für diese kreative arbeit
ausgelegt ist mit seinem 16 kern reisen
95 1950 ickx und 64 gigabyte
arbeitsspeicher die verbaute grafikkarte
nvidia rtx 30 90 hat schon bei meinem
projekt gaming pc aus dem 3d drucker
realistische renderings in echtzeit
geliefert und das machen wir jetzt hier
auf ca
ich finds richtig cool also ich bin aus
allerdings wieder die magie einfach mega
geil dass du zu sehen wie das in
echtzeit geht ich habe diesen radikalen
angefangen als ich 15 war und da habe
ich einfach teilweise stunden aus dem
bild gewartet rein optisch finde ich
muss man auch nichts ändern hier kann
ich sogar noch mit tiefenschärfe das
anzeigen lassen und ich kann natürlich
auch in echtzeit dieses 3d modell jetzt
einfach herum bewegen mehr nichts quasi
schon den schönen gründern sie normal
bearbeitet man 3d modellieren diese
komplett unschönen ansicht hier ich bin
sogar noch einen schritt weiter gegangen
und habe einmal das komplette fahrzeug
verhalten und die steuerung in einer
virtuellen welt simuliert mit der unreal
engine samt raytracing wobei meine rtx
30 90 voll auf ihre kosten kommt und es
ist einfach wirklich erstaunlich wie
realistisch das alles aussieht ohne dass
man für jedes einzelne bild ewig warten
muss so wie ich das man früher kennen
sondern einfach in echtzeit schaut euch
diese reflexion an das glas das feuer
einfach geil danke übrigens an alex er
bei der technischen realisierung von
dieser simulation erheblich geholfen hat
finde ich ja jetzt muss man das ganze
zeit nur noch in die realität umsetzen
ich hab ja verwirklichen so viele sachen
besteht aus elektromotor akkus manches
werde ich von vor dem bau sind
ausschlachten aber das meiste mit enten
aus holz gesägt und dann lackiert oder
sowie die felgen und räder 3d gedreht
[Musik]
aber es geht gleich weiter mit den
technischen dingen normal würde ich
jetzt diese zeichnung mit bleistift und
geodreieck auf sie übertragen und dann
aussehen was ewig dauern würde aber ich
habe mir einen laser gekauft er schon
seit ein paar wochen herumliegt und
jetzt benutze ich ihn zum ersten mal
[Musik]
so ist gut geworden sich jetzt noch
deutlich dicker machen können ich habe
jetzt nur mit halber kraft gemacht um
ist es hier ein bisschen schwach aber
auf die gleiche weise kann ich jetzt
alle holzteile machen und dann zusammen
verbinden also es ist ruhig mal die
löcher einmal
dass das ding ist 2 mm
und das muss perfekt sein
[Musik]
so haben als alle teile einmal gelasert
ist mir wenn ich die aber nicht mit der
laubsäge aussehen sondern ich habe mir
so eine deko pier seeger gekauft die
macht es einfach mit elektrisch und das
soll deutlich schneller unsaubere gehen
[Musik]
zur die holzteile sind alle fertig jetzt
muss ich allerdings noch an den seiten
ein bisschen abschlägen die münchen am
ende zusammen stecken kann
[Musik]
eigentlich kann man nicht arbeiten mit
metall wie die pest wenn ich einfach
keinen bock auf metallstaub in meiner
wohnung und vor allem nicht in meinen
augen hat aber für dieses eine bauteile
lässt sich leider einfach nicht
vermeiden das ist für die lenkung das
muss stabil sein deswegen werde ich mir
toll sagen müssen und auch hier kann ich
die super neue in zukunftsweisende
technologie der esa da draußen ein
bisschen helfen nehmen wir das was ich
hier aus sägen und bohren muss einfach
einmal bereits vorzeichen dafür muss ich
allerdings der kann nicht einfach auf
alle laser ist meine große fläche hier
mit seinem komischen filzstift anmalen
so dass nikolaus ab damit in den laser
[Musik]
und das was gebracht hat keine ahnung
ja schade ich versuche trotzdem mal mit
hinterlassen 3d drucker als nächstes
können wir uns um die fenster fenster
war natürlich jetzt nicht unbedingt auf
echtem glas der vielleicht nicht ganz so
schlau sofern wir hier bastl glas ja das
ist auch durchsichtig hat noch so eine
schutzfolie die das dann noch bisschen
klarer macht und die werden auch hier
mit sägen lada konnte ich das jetzt
nicht so einfach lasermann könnte
farbiges plexiglas laser aber durch ist
nicht da bleibt er sein ich hab ich
papier gelesen und das nehme ich jetzt
einfach schablonen masken kurz doch
nicht anders und der brille damit ich
nicht in sicht mancher hatte so aufgeht
wie gut
[Musik]
so oder dinge schön
oha das sogar richtig durchsichtig
[Musik]
dass auch wenn ich keine glasteile sind
perfekt geschnitten halbwegs allerdings
sollen natürlich schön mit tönen sein
und nicht so labbrig weiß sondern schön
heißt
allerdings soll die natürlich durch
licht sein sondern schön getönt und
dafür habe ich eine schwarze farbe und
er muss jetzt mal probieren ob das
überhaupt zu erstellen
[Musik]
ich bin nicht sehr cool aus
so jetzt werden tatsachen geschaffen
nach über anderthalb wochen der planung
recherche
informationen alle möglichen platz
bilder kopf aber ist es fertig als ich
vor mir haben ja alle 3d druck teile
einmal fertig wenn alle teile für die
karosserie fertig wir haben alle glas
paneele fertig und werde natürlich auch
unser schönes saskia unsere grundlage
fertig aber auch die ganze technik und
so zum beispiel die elektromotoren hier
parat oder im akku packs und natürlich
ein bordcomputer hier den schürzen nano
ja und das alles werden wir zusammen
bauen so und da mal ein mal hier in
guten elektromotor und das lustig ist es
eigentlich dass ich das ding einfach
eine power bank anstecken kann und sich
erst dann was riecht sondern ist ein
bisschen besser zu verdeutlichen und
funktioniert übrigens genauso wie so ein
generator den ich also schon mal selber
aus komplette rohstoff gebaut habe
[Musik]
der dual motor ist verbaut bringt
allerdings noch gar nichts mehr weil die
frau nicht auch boden kriegen dazu haben
wir die räder bestehen aus felge und
reifen noch nicht schön gesäubert aber
in 3d gruppe entstanden und ganz
besonders hier aus gummi was super cool
ist und deutlich mehr grip auf den boden
bringt das ist so krass dass man so was
einmal aus und regiobus kriegt dass man
ein verbiegen kann das rad kommen es um
die frage gerungen einmal sagt
runterbringt felge und
da läuft
doch
angetrieben werden aber einmal
festschrauben hinten geht schon mal 4
vorne dafür brauche ich einen stepper
motor ein
[Musik]
das was ich hier gerade zusammen bauer
ist übrigens das lenkgetriebe mit dem
die reifen später nach links und nach
rechts bewegt werden die art wie das
mechanisch funktioniert ist eigentlich
ziemlich genial aber auch total simpel
die rotation des lenkers oder bei uns
des schrittmotor wir übertragen auf die
reifen das wird total dass sich doch 3d
gedruckt hat auf mich hat das auch alles
aus
[Musik]
ich war jetzt zum battery pack ist ja
ein elektroauto da kommen akkurat doch
viel zu teures kauft zwei davon posten
irgendwie 30 euro im internet
an den strom werden die motoren gesteckt
kann man dann später über den
bordcomputer steuern was wieviel strom
kriegt und demnach halten wie viel gas
gibt
soll jetzt natürlich das herzstück
irgendwo so ganz ungestört werden
irgendwo muss natürlich dann auch später
mal die ganze künstliche intelligenz und
so weil uns vor berechnet werden das
kissen mini computer setzen nano wenig
liebe weise von nvidia bekommen habe und
das ist ein kompletter pc du das geld
winziges und andere in unserem auto
passen werden soll ich war noch mal ein
lüfter darauf die ganze rechenpower
wir rechen power muss ja gekühlt werden
auch in so einem kleinen pc damit das
auto später mal weiß wo es hinfallen
muss braucht auch eine kamera die wir
darauf installiert
so sieht jetzt noch nicht wirklich nach
einem auto aus aber hat alles was man
braucht außer natürlich die verkleidung
bevor werde ich aber jetzt also ohne
verkleidung solange ich noch eine ganzen
einzelteile rankommen und das denkmal
programmieren und ich habe noch keine
ahnung wie das geht kann man bestimmt
ändern hoffentlich ohne jetzt lange um
den heißen brei herumzureden das alles
einzurichten war für mich als laien echt
ne riesen nummer etliche dinge
konfigurieren in so einem textzeilen
fenster bei dem meine nachbarn wenn sie
durchs fenster reinschauen denken werden
ich hätte mich gerade in der einen
staubsaugerroboter rein nach langen hin
und her aber
das gehört
ist das geil ich tippe mal am pc eine
eins rein
und er macht aber was obwohl damit kein
kabel zwischen
also wie lange das gedauert hat
schon ziemlich geil nur noch spannender
wird halt jetzt auch das ding auch fährt
ein bisschen aber gibt gas junge junge
der feder von hellas funktioniere das
voll geil und jetzt kann ich das auch
wichtig programmieren
[Musik]
taste lustig ist theoretisch bevor man
den ganzen coolen scheiße aber machen
auch mit der kamera hier und so weiter
und so fort haben bevor das teil einfach
klein gesteuert durch die bude fairen
auch programmiert durch die bude wäre
dann vielleicht automobile produziert er
dafür mag jetzt die verkleidung um
endlich soll er aussehen wie ein auto
das ding so jetzt kommt die verkleidung
für die räder
so die verkleidung kommt dran
jetzt sind wir richtig formaten
freigeist
[Musik]
lücken gut
denn er ist
fleißig und richtig schön geworden und
natürlich sagen machen wir eine
spritztour
[Musik]
oh
ich freue mich wie ein kleines kind
ok also ich hab hier einmal eine ganz
neue tastatur läuft über meinen pc der
renten schild hin zu videos einmal fährt
[Musik]
das übel lustig ist auch ultra lustig
einmal irgendwas im echten leben mit aws
die zu steuern
[Musik]
es war weiß noch nicht mal die hälfte
der power die ich da aktiviert habt
volle kraft voraus
also die reifenrutsche hat übel durch
[Musik]
mehrere trifft die power ist damit ein
bisschen besser den reifen kommt noch
besser auf den boden bringen aber das
auto fährt und es sieht immer noch nicht
alles was jetzt natürlich aus aller
spannendste ist ob das teil auch selber
fahren kann und dafür brauchen wir jetzt
mal ein parcours ich arme eine kleine
straße nach eine kurvige spur in der
mein auto ganz von alleine fahren soll
und nach einigen testläufen fährt es von
selbstlos und fährt die strecke wie von
geisterhand während ich im hintergrund
einfach nur zusehen
hierfür habe ich aber jede lenkung und
jedes beschleunigung von hand
programmiert mit dem schätzen nano den
ich als bordcomputer verbaut habe kann
man aber auch mit einer kamera echtes
autonomes fahren und hinderniserkennung
ermöglichen aber das ist etwas für ein
zukünftiges video
ein selbst gebautes auto also ich finds
mega geil ich vielen dank an nvidia und
mit complus unterstützen von diesem
video und für diese recht maschine in
der es alles geplant modelliert
skizziert und simuliert habe und genau
für diese art von kreative arbeit sind
hier ein videostudio treiber geschaffen
die auf jedem ein videostudio pc von
willkommen freund zu dir zu egal ob für
blender ist in dvd oder radioprogramme
jeder kann seinen pc beim abkommen
individuell auf seine bedürfnisse
zuschneiden den link dazu findet eine
video beschreibung ich mache mir jetzt
direkt ans nächste verrückte projekt
wenn ich das nicht angehen lassen wollt
ihr wisst was zu tun ist macht's gut